they watch as if in fair things could
get worse in germany
and the rising waters where the rhino
and mosul rivers meet and kublens offer
no reassurance
[Music]
dozens have lost their lives to flooding
in this region and there's little
confidence the struggle for residents is
over yet
in earthshat west of cologne several
houses collapsed
others are in jeopardy but work to
protect them was impossible with roads
washed away
and this is a scene repeated over and
over across this nation
the village of olof has literally been
ripped apart by the flood waters
roads homes and properties destroyed but
it's the loss of life here which has
broken many
you don't expect people to die in a
flood in germany
you expect it maybe in poor countries
but you don't expect it here
but it was all too fast too quick this
it was a flat
inside the home that has belonged to his
family for five generations
bird nettersheim cannot control his
emotions when he thinks of what has
happened
and how he will ever rebuild
he and his son were in the property when
the floods hit and say
it was terrifying we tried to seal doors
and then rise more and more
and then the doors were breaking you
hear here crashes outside
this whole gate was breaking um
it was a shock definitely and
especially when the front door was
breaking and the flood was going through
if
anyone would have been in the lower
floor would have been that
he blames climate change saying the
weather and the world is changing
and worries that families like his will
go through more pain in the future
rivers are still running fast and high
and there are now real concerns for a
nearby reservoir
if there's more heavy rain and the
structure fails the water could consume
three villages the reservoir and its dam
are being monitored carefully
fire crews told us it's a critical
situation
and as a result residents have been
ordered out of homes
closest to the danger forced to leave
not knowing what will be left when they
return
and that's a challenge not just for the
people living here but government
is therefore already clear today that
our state is experiencing a flood
disaster
of historic dimensions we'll repair
houses
rebuild bridges repair traffic routes
but the lives lost in the floods are
irreplaceable
but this is a disaster which spans
nations in neighbouring belgium some
towns were near deserted
residents forced out of properties
underwater and rescue services
struggling to prevent further deaths
in the netherlands the military worked
to control the flow of the mass river
while police helped evacuate some
low-lying neighborhoods
in the southern dutch province of
limburg as floods encroached on the area
and with more rain predicted the work of
the emergency services won't be over
anytime soon michelle clifford sky news
germany